[Music]
so far we have understood that
integration is a process by which we can
find an
original function from its derivative
this process is also called
anti-differentiation
let's understand this process using some
examples
here we have functions sine x x cubed by
and e raised to x now
what will be the derivative of these
functions
yes the derivative of sine x will be
cos x the derivative of x cubed by 3
will be x square and the derivative of
e raised to x will be e raised to x
now if cos x is the derivative of sine x
then by the definition of integration
what can be said about
sine x yes correct
sine x will be the anti-derivative or
the
integral of cos x similarly
we can say the same for the other
functions as well
now consider these functions sine x
plus 2 and sine x minus 10.
what will be the derivative of these
functions
yes both the functions will have cos x
as the derivative as the derivative of a
constant
is 0. so does that mean both
sine x plus 2 and sine x minus 10
will be integral of cos x
yes they are this is because the
integral of
any function is not unique
the function cos x has infinitely many
integrals which can be denoted by sine x
plus c where c belongs to real numbers
and is called the constant of
integration
similarly the integrals of other
functions can be expressed as shown
so in general if there is a function f
such
that d by dx of f of x
is equal to f of x then the integral of
f of x is given by f of x plus c
where c is some constant
the integral equation can be written as
shown
this here denotes integral of f with
respect to x
where f of x is called the integrand
and x is the variable of integration
now as we already know the formulae for
the derivatives of
many important functions we can use them
to define the corresponding formulae for
the integrals
as shown these formulae
are also referred to as the standard
formulae of
integration does by using these formulae
we can find the integrals of different
functions
next we will be understanding the
geometrical interpretation
of indefinite integral so
see you in the next video
you